[Music]
it's okay to be different it's okay to
not look like the normal person it's
okay to get outside your comfort zone
and be courageous even if people don't
like it along this positive then you
should press forward with it my name is
Isaiah Griffin and I'm a bodybuilder
when I was 17 18 I developed this
condition called key noise basically
wanting your body over the hills itself
started as bumps every now and then that
will burst open that look like regular
acne then they started to just connect
and make the web basically on my chest
in earlier stages of having my keloids
honestly didn't understand it or how to
feel about it I wasn't in a mirror so
much there won't be times where I would
just wash my face turn the lights off
mentally mess with my confidence I had a
depression from it but mainly weren't
about focus on what other people think
kind of been in a shoe but slowly but
surely I just started wearing tank tops
in a gym to where I will feel like I'm
overcoming whatever is better than one
outside or inside there was something
new something completely different I
want to work towards being a world
champion but this journey is more about
self-improvement more than it is
receiving any medals anything being a
champion it is nice but I need to see
the real meaning what I'm doing when I
see myself in the mirror now just see
myself and love myself I look past the
scars and just see a person who doesn't
want to accept the norm it's African
proverb if there's no enemy within the
enemy outside can do us no harm
[Music]
[Music]
Peter Kostis Melissa Judith
they say this is awesome if I clean up
there they saw us in it Master San
Sereno tan Jovi not a guinea a single
carpet I did not say that you know Jerry
Tarkanian apt Mahoney autonomy
Mitaka McKenna Jana has to do it for the
other kid even dr. Holliday cause a
kidney we're I love this in the tech we
didn't get any customers so you know mo
no mo Mata Tata no sato through channels
to stay because Scott over the akhirah
good I know it or not it cannot be you
know mutated hands down over there so
that's you know Stepanov City salon you
hire a machine or a snake after that the
anova so the voluntary departure
for the three among Canadian experiment
changing the power down post cannot even
or speedo
so up say there is suing you know
technical a Circassian engine icon at
home we must met
Kumud a couple walls there yep his god
amon-ra single drive up you know a
company Nagatomo see what occurs to you
will not go to morality but or say
bioanalytical Marriott center cute kitty
here in the old I already know vinegar
imitate occur sooner written yesterday
she uttered a poem I wrote it so reverse
rejection no Cara Cano severity Oni
esquina Pato so Jamie articulate ANOVA
keyboard sure I am ever to harnessing
and go to Asia services
[Music]
[Music]
when Milo brother Lucas was born my
parents would came that he went locker
talk and the doctors even said he might
not make it to his tenth birthday
but today a few months away from his
tenth birthday we're doing our 15th
triathlon together
my name is Noah Aldridge and this is my
brother Lucas Aldridge I guess I'm
talking Noah is 11 and Lucas is 9 and
Lucas was born with a rare genetic
neurologic condition called listen
zeppeli he's been able to walk unable to
talk he's unable to feed himself but
despite all of his challenges happiest
little boy that you ever meet about four
years ago our boys started doing
triathlons together in most cases that
wouldn't be a big deal a lot of kids do
triathlons but there's something very
special about the way our boys do
triathlons I pull Lucas in a raft for
the swim portion then I pull him in a
bike cart during their bike and I push
him in a running cart during the run I
wanted to do this because Lucas can't do
things like we can he can't really play
sport so this is something we could do
together currently we're training for
our 15th try on which is this weekend
before the race I always feel nervous I
don't think I'll ever get over that I
just don't want to hurt Lucas I don't
care if I win the race he just has to be
okay
[Music]
before the race Lukas gets serious and
he gets his race face on and they're
ready to compete they swim around 200
yards then they transition to a bike
they'll go usually about three to five
miles and then they'll run about a mile
NOAA's strong physically and especially
mentally because he's truly only doing
these races for his brother sometimes I
feel like that it's gotta be over soon
all right but I just hear Lucas that's
how he says go faster every day is
precious with that little boy I try to
soak in the experience because we don't
know how long the boys will be able to
do triathlons together any one of them
could be their last what these boys
accomplish gives me immense sense of
pride knowing Lucas for an inspiration
people see these two young boys and that
gives them hope and it gives them
encouragement to go out and tackle life
challenges
[Music]
I'm not sick when I run like I'm really
I'm just so normal
you wouldn't think someone who goes
unconscious like 14 times a day runs
like you just wouldn't put it that way
[Music]
my name is Katie cook I'm 20 years old I
live in Dublin Ireland and I love
running I was diagnosed with two types
of epilepsy when - nine years old a one
of which which is frontal lobe epilepsy
so at the moment I have 14 seizures in
the 24-hour period
they used to be 1617 so we're coming
down slightly which is whew I was
getting really bad dizziness from my
medicine - and into the hospital and
they loaded me which is a term for
epileptics when you're going on like a
new medicine and I didn't wake up until
6 days later I was a mobile for the
goths up 2 years I moved from being in a
wheelchair to being in the same her
frame what I gradually started getting
back into running it kinda gave me this
newfound energy I don't know why I put
on my ready boots and started running I
feel like it's so cliched but you kind
of feel like on top of the world that
you could do anything like I don't feel
sick anymore until I have a seizure
I don't like that much you are it's
amazing feeling like all the endorphins
like pulsing or your body and it's great
like I like it's honestly like amazing I
try to learn for most my runs like
during the week however I do have a pal
for my races like official races which
is dr. Colin tardy
[Music]
so I have two roles so first of all I'm
her doctor
the other role I play which is to be her
partner in running and my job is to make
sure that when katie has a seizure if
she's running that nobody carts her off
the course no procedure so before I knew
Katie she would run races and if they
were in public people would you know
quite reasonably insists that she be
carried off the course which to her
displeasure so my job is to say no you
know that I am her doctor and that she's
fine that she'll recover and then she
gets up and she runs I don't let
anything really get in the way of living
life at all I just don't think it's the
way to go I suppose yeah I don't I don't
let that burlap sea get in the way at
all
[Music]
[Music]
well it's a 360-degree game there's no
padding there is a high risk involved in
it because it is a full-contact sport
and you really can cop it from any angle
but we're pretty tough and you get
straight back up in the coffee I'm Chloe
and I'm a women's football I let's go
girls
[Music]
IFL or the Australian Football League is
best described as a combination of rugby
football and soccer I think if you asked
any Australian it's a really big deal it
defines us it's a part of our culture I
think everyone has AFL team that they
support my uncle played football for
Collingwood so I grew up watching him
and I immediately wanted to do it back
when I was a little girl actually played
football for three to four years but
then there's that drop-off that a lot of
girls have because there is no pathway
into a woman's sporting career in 2017 a
women's league was officially introduced
good stretch for all Australian but if a
woman's changed the path of life for me
that I never thought I'd have it's
brought out the little girl's dream that
I had back when I did play football
I think the AFL women's is breaking down
a lot of barriers that once existed
amongst women in sport no matter what
race what sexual identity you are it
really doesn't matter and anyone can
play some people just don't agree that
women should be playing football so
that's probably a challenge that I face
and that the whole league face as well
the best way to react to all the
criticism is just not to react at all
and keep doing what we enjoy one hope
that I have is that if any little girl a
boy looks on the TV they know full well
that that's a sport that they can go
into no matter if it's being played by
men or women
you
[Music]